Holland is not a country despite
suggestions to the contrary all over
Amsterdam North and South Holland are
just two coastal provinces in a country
officially called the Netherlands and
the government tired of its biggest city
being a byword for legalized
prostitution and recreational drug use
wants a rebrand so with a new PR push
it's asking us to forget Holland and
think only of the Netherlands for the
whole rest of the world I think Holland
is quite clear what it is some small
spot somewhere on the earth where Dutch
people live and to change that image
around to change that idea of Holland
into the Netherlands I think it's quite
a task it's quite a difficult task
everywhere you look from branded clocks
to other souvenirs the name Holland
dominates it's no surprise tourists
aren't sure where they are what would
you call this country
no I think Poland
her name's wrong Manson what do you call
this country we're in now oh yeah that
London you alright
Netherland the crazy bossy yes yes
Hollanders estate of Netherlands is the
country and today officially they want
you to stop calling it Holland they
wanted to call it the Netherlands in
Amsterdam they're struggling to cope
with a record number of tourists 42
million people are expected to visit
this country by 2030 that's up from
around 20 million now and to manage that
the government hopes that this
rebranding will encourage people to
explore outside overcrowded Amsterdam to
the country beyond the two provinces of
Holland Burnett Smith al-jazeera
Amsterdam in the Netherlands